[Music]
April back on the program the defensive
end by the way cliff is the answer to a
very very good trivia question and I
think you know this cliff I I hope you
do do you know the answer to the great
trivia question you're involved in no
I'd like another question okay all right
the deal well I think I'll give away the
answer by the question the only player
in NFL history to win a Super Bowl after
having a pellet on a team that didn't
win a game yeah only player to do that
I'm glad I win in that way it was Oh a
16th in Super Bowl message was about 60
that would have been a little tougher to
take that you go from that high to that
low but take us back to it when you
don't win what does it do to the team as
far as chemistry and pointing fingers
and you know well I was a rookie that
year um so I was just trying to figure
out i'll try to figure myself out so i
figure out how this whole NFL thing
works you know and you know we're going
through these games and we're losing it
for me and the competitor that I am I'm
like well I want to be the guy that's
not the reason why you know I was trying
to still fight for a job and all these
different things and honestly I wasn't
really paying attention to how bad we
really were until like the offseason
where you know it's kind of like
embarrassing to tell people you know you
play for the lines at the time because
we're the only team that ever did that
so it was it was it was weird though it
was a weird look where you're just just
trying to figure out who I am and who
I'm gonna be as NFL player how many
friends do you still have on the lines
Oh nobody's there all the person there
still is Matt Stafford and then my
d-line coach he's still there and he's
uh he's about the only guy that
communicate with still like the golden
team is there so that's a former
teammate in Seattle so overcommit yeah
yeah can you be friends are you friends
yeah no go taste good guy man heck of a
ballplayer
don't have any issues with them you know
I don't have to cover so you know
nothing nothing wrong with that
situation you know that's that's for
sure man those guys so but we're cool
but you now you get to hit Stafford
whereas when you were with the lines in
practice you weren't able to hit him oh
yeah oh yeah that's a little different
you get give them opportunities but you
know stuff is easy he's doing some great
things man he's grown he's grown up so
much as a quarterback you knows from
when I was there too so now but uh you
know if I give my opportunities i'm
definitely take more shots ever
accidentally hit Russell Wilson and
practice no no I like my job too much to
do anything like that oh yeah the
quarterbacks were registered for a
reason you know you want touch those
guys what would Pete Sadie if you did
that um I don't know that's a good
question i don't wanna put him in that
situation to have to say anything to me
um i'm a true veteran i stay away from
the quarterbacks now I've seen them get
after guys for getting close to him and
I don't want to be that guy would you
rather play in bad weather or good
weather great weather her rather face
wait don't wear you know what what what
kind of temperature you're going to have
you know we played in Minnesota last
year and that was terrible oh my god oh
yeah that day i think they said i got-
like 10 15 or something crazy like that
it was it was bad man um unnecessary
football weather and they should cancel
that one but at what point does it
affect you or what at what point does it
not affect you when you're playing cold
I think it affects you from the jump I
mean can't even warm up like you
normally do you know it's so cold you
like you know what I'll just wait to the
team comes out and warm up together like
it throws everything off it's extremely
cold your fingers go numb immediately
says you go outside it's not fun I'll
tell you that there's always something
going on with you guys now I Richard
Sherman's boycotting the media I saw
that because he say right I mean how
much fun do you have with all those
personalities because I don't know if
here you turn around and somebody saying
something
doing something and now Richard
Sherman's boycotting the media yeah well
you know you gotta you gotta you gotta
gotta 53 guys in the locker room I mean
everybody's gonna be different
everyone's going to have their own thing
going on me personally I can't keep up
with all of it but as far as for
teammates we have great teammate sermons
that awesome guy he's a great teammate
but you know everybody everybody has
their their their thing that they they
they feel like they want to do and the
cool thing is co-chair allows us to be
ourselves and that's what happens
sometimes how often does Richard Sherman
bring up that he went to Stanford he
doesn't bring you guys know at least I
with me not with me and Linda cuz i
would have Purdue so you know and yeah I
have a little bit of clout to but not
not staffer cloud of course but you know
he doesn't bring it with me though well
if you saw this story cliff and what
happened in the clemson ohio state game
where the defensive player is seen
grabbing for clemson grabbing you know
what I'm talking about yes but my phone
was blowing up like this what football
is it do you do that stuff I hope not
that's crazy I mean I don't know what I
don't know what the situation was i well
there's no situation actually Oh warrant
anything like that but that was a little
weird that was a little little weird I
don't know what they have going on right
there but I would have splashed out
personally but that's just me ok but
what what what is allowable in the pile
itself that's not allowable I mean
that's for you if we can't see any that
was in out the open but if we had the
big pile there what what is allowable
well I've heard of because I've never
been a part of it I mean I've heard of
guys you know pension punching you
no different things like that but I've
never seen nothing like what that video
like never been in a policy my just
grabs you like that and that's a little
weird just Michael Bennett we're
children's shoulder pads I think he
wears uh the lingerie league but he were
is he the goofiest guy on the team by
far yeah he's the goofiest craziest guy
on the team but he has he means well he
just has his moments where he just
decides he wants to say whatever and
whatever he's thinking about he's
definitely let you know it but he's he's
a great teammate though the Seahawks
will go to the Super Bowl if if we play
our kind of ball which means you know
stopping the run on defense getting
after the quarterback and office doing
what they do you know putting up points
but i think i think it's i think it's
very possible congrats on the great
season cliff and good luck against your
former team we appreciate your time
thanks for having me everything that's a
cliff April the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
[Music]